Kevin arrows I was in the introduction I
mean your success is extraordinary how
you know I'm certain to say the guy that
spilled on three and a half billion
dollars my success has been all right
sorry to bring you down you walk down
here high as a kite and I was like well
no but you must get soft in the streets
and stuff like that now high usually by
people collecting for charity I ask the
same twin if I have copies a twenty five
pilot copies of my own DVD takes balls
man yes same them okay good question do
not Lily can you understand anything I
said no I got something about balls yeah
he said balls yeah if it's tables no
shouldn't you seriously not understand
not very much I was gonna kind of
question him as he was going along but
that's with write a show and a manicure
than one gig a guy complimented me
approached me after the set and it goes
a man are you actually Scottish and I
said yes and it goes [ __ ] man your
English is pretty good
because without talking of Scottish was
chris hemsworth you did Scottish in the
Huntsman yeah what it was it was a
Celtic pod
I had a great reviewer tell me that it
was the worst Glaswegian accent since
the Fat Bastard I wasn't doing
Glaswegian either side that was in my
defense I was a Celtic five it was a
Celtic fantasy snow white world Scottish
influence kind of accent so that gives
you a whole broad range to do whatever
help you want but that I can I hear a
little bit too now you get on just do a
little bit suppers pretty yeah it took
me relax laments are flying in God isn't
it a lot that's why do we die so young
in Scotland because it's just exhausting
it's almost no effort you know it runs
late and you're head of you Sam have you
performed in Australia though yes yeah
so don't we love you I swear to God I
love you
yeah I played Australia I've not played
Scotland but I played Australia and by
the reaction I'm amazed that I went over
at all what do you mean I'm just saying
they seem to understand Kevin very well
we don't even tell you now
and even I'm having trouble with Chris a
little bit Norma's on me I can
understand you well that's the main
thing yes I find this references as well
you need to change certain references
when you perform wait are you talking to
me
beatenest ex-im can I follow up just go
nice really had a good time and it just
goes shaped Charlie like blend in and
you know research and just getting
heckled left and right about you know
come spend some time in my shell baby